new covet 19 boosters that specifically
target the latest versions of omicron
will now be available after the u.s food
and drug administration authorized are
used on august 31st
these new shots come from pharmaceutical
companies modern ag plus pfizer and its
partner biontech but there's a key step
in the normal fda decision making
process that was skipped this time
around here's how these two shots differ
from the original doses and when you can
expect to get them
unlike all previously authorized coveted
vaccines these new shots haven't
completed human clinical trials that
means their initial authorization
depended on data from studies on mice
tests from shots that targeted an
earlier omicron subvariant plus the
safety and efficacy record of the
original shots
rolling out vaccines without clinical
trials isn't an entirely new concept the
flu shots you get every year typically
don't go through clinical trials because
the viruses mutate so rapidly if every
year regulators waited to test them
before rolling them out flu shots might
not be available to protect people when
they were most needed and it's a similar
situation now with cobit
the new shots will target three covet
strains the original one that emerged in
wuhan china in late 2019 plus two
omicron sub-variants ba-4 and ba-5 in
recent months these newer omicron
sub-variants have become the dominant
forms in the u.s in large part because
they've gotten so good at evading
antibodies what's in these new booster
shots is essentially the same as what
was in the original shots except for
modifications that target the omicron
sub-variants so regulators felt
comfortable rolling them out
the potential for fall and winter
surgeries adds urgency to updating the
currently available shots which have
been shown to be less effective against
omicron but the original shots continued
to keep people out of the hospital which
is a key measure of their effectiveness
and research has shown that protection
against omicron increases when people
get the original boosters given all that
some vaccine experts told the journal
that they were uncomfortable with the
idea of giving the new boosters to
millions of people without large-scale
clinical testing human trials for the
new shots from moderna and biser
biontech have already started but the
results won't be available for months
now that the new shots have been
authorized biden's fall coveted booster
campaign is set to begin once the cdc
signs off the campaign will ship more
than 170 million doses of the new
vaccine to states pharmacies and other
vaccination sites only people who are
fully vaccinated will be able to get the
modified booster according to the
administration's planning guide
anyone 12 and older can get the shot
from pfizer for modern as you'll need to
be at least 18 years old each person
would get one shot of the new booster at
least two months after their last jab
the booster campaign is expected to face
challenges including people just being
tired of taking covert vaccines health
officials hope that by combining the
rollout of the new boosters with annual
flu shots we'll increase the covered
vaccination rates plus we're dealing
with a virus that keeps mutating setting
us up to need additional vaccine updates
in the future